안녕하세요. 기술로트 알렉입니다. 이 전에 IT 전체를 설명드린 영상이 굉장히 많은 분들이 봐주시고
또 많은 분들이 좋다라고 하셔서 관련된 후속 영상을 이렇게 준비를 했습니다.
이번 영상의 주제는 기존의 대부분의 시스템들이 프론트앤드 백앤드로 구성된다고 했던 그 내용을 조금 더 기술적으로 펼쳐서 전체를 한번 설명드리는 그런 내용이 되겠습니다.
좀 어려워 보일 수도 있는데요. 이 영상을 끝까지 들으신다면 이 내용이 다 이해가 되실 거고 또 대부분의 시스템들이 이렇게 구성이 되기 때문에 끝까지 한번 들어보시는 것을 추천을 드립니다.
바로 시작할게요. 먼저 이렇게 프론트앤드가 있습니다.
그리고 백앤드. 백앤드에는 크게 서버 그리고 이렇게 데이터베이스가 있습니다.
요새 한번 말씀드렸던 프론트앤드와 백앤드로 구성됩니다. 라고 했던 부분이고 이렇게 해서 사이에 이러한 통신을 기반으로 해가지고 데이터를 주고 받게 됩니다.
프론트앤드 쪽부터 보면요. 프론트앤드의 가장 대표적인 요소들이 있다면 프론트앤드는 화면을 개발한다.
그리고 이벤트 처리를 한다. 데이터 송수신을 한다. 라는 것이 프론트앤드의 주요한 부분입니다.
화면 웹이든 앱이든 화면을 프론트앤드라고 했고요. 여기서 중요한 것은 웹도 그렇고 앱도 그렇고 사용자들의 사용을 기다리고 있다가 버튼이 눌리거나
무언가 액션이 오면 그것을 처리해줍니다. 그것을 이벤트 처리라고 하고요. 대부분의 앱이나 웹은 통신을 기반으로 하고 있기 때문에
이 사용자의 요청에 통신이 시작되고 통신에 의해서 데이터를 받아오고 그것을 화면에 보여주게 됩니다. 그것이 데이터 송수신에 대한 부분입니다.
그래서 프론트앤드는 사실 이 세 가지가 거의 대부분의 개발 요소이고 대부분의 기능이다라고 보셔도 됩니다.
그러면 우리가 쉽게 이해할 수 있는 화면부터 한번 보면 웹이 있고요. 여기에는 앱이 있습니다. 웹은 웹 브라우저에서 URL을 입력하고 엔터를 치게 됩니다.
이때 URL이라는 것은 도메인으로 되어 있습니다. 이 도메인은 사람들이 인지하기 쉽게 만든 이름입니다.
htps로 시작해서 ww.google.com 이런 식으로 가죠. 이런 것들이 도메인인데요. 사실 도메인으로는 접속을 할 수가 없습니다.
도메인은 사람들이 이해하기 쉽게 만든 이름이다라고 보시면 되고요. 실질적으로 도메인을 ip로 바꾸어 주는 것이 dns라는 것이고요.
이 도메인 이름 서버에는 도메인과 함께 ip 주소가 있습니다. 그래서 그 ip 주소를 받아오게 되는 거예요. ip가 있어야 많이 인터넷 접속을 할 수 있고 어떤 서버로 접속을 할 수가 있습니다.
이때 사용되는 웹에서 사용되는 프로토콜은 htp입니다. htp는 hypertexttransfer 프로토콜입니다.
hypertext라는 것은 문서상에서 이렇게 링크가 있는 것들을 hypertext라고 했고요. 그것을 주고받는 프로토콜.
프로토콜은 서로 간의 약속입니다. 규약. 그래서 이런 링크가 있는 문서를 주고받는 프로토콜이다 해서 htp라고 하고요.
여기에 s에 붙는다면 s는 cq. 그래서 보안이 더 적용된 프로토콜이다 라고 보시면 됩니다.
그렇게 해서 접속을 해서 요청을 하게 됩니다. 여기 주소로 서버에 접속이 되고 사실 여기에 숨겨진 것이 최초에는 대부분 index.html이 숨겨져 있고
이 index.html 파일을 요청하게 되고 그 파일을 응답으로 받게 됩니다. 그 응답의 내용에는 html, css, javascript가 포함되어 있고요.
여기에 또 하나는 이미지가 있습니다. 그렇게 되면 우리가 웹 브라우저 상에서 화면에 보여지는 구성 요소는 html이라는 틀 그리고 html을 꾸며주는 css
동적인 역할은 javascript 그리고 화면에 이미지, 이런 것들을 통해서 웹 화면이 구성되는 것이죠.
이렇게 클란트는 웹 브라우저 그리고 웹 브라우저가 웹 서버로 접속해서 데이터를 가져오는 이 역할을 해주는 것이 웹 서버이고요.
이제 앱을 보게 되면 앱이라는 형태는 단말, 모바일에 설치되는 것이죠. 클라인드 프로그램 자체가 폰에 탑재가 되는 것이 앱이고 이 앱은 안드로이드 os가 있고 ios가 있습니다.
그래서 안드로이드는 자바코틀린 언어를 통해서 안드로이드 스튜디오로 만들기도 하고요.
리액트 네이티브, 플러터 같은 프레임워크를 통해서 안드로이드도 만들고 ios도 만들기도 합니다.
그리고 ios는 swift, objective, c 이런 언어들을 통해서 만들기도 하는데요.
이 iOS와 안드로이드는 따로따로 개발이 할 필요가 있고 리액트 네이티브나 플러터라는 것을 통해서는 멀티OS, 안드로이드도 지원하고 ios도 지원하는 형태로 또 만들 수 있습니다.
이 자세한 내용은 제가 앱 형태에서 한번 자세히 풀었으니까 영상을 참조해주시면 될 것 같고요.
저는 api를 통해서 서버로 요청을 하고 서버에서 응답을 받게 됩니다.
이때 이 프로토콜 서로 간에 주고받는 프로토콜은 http, https를 사용하는데요.
여기서 제가 http나 https를 동시에 말씀드린 이유는 지금 만약에 사용으로 서비스를 만들고 우리가 접속하고 있는 모든 것들은 https라고 보시면 됩니다.
이때 api가 접속을 하는 곳은 was라는 웹 어플리케이션 서버입니다.
이건 서버 쪽에서 좀 더 자세히 말씀드릴게요.
앱에서 api로 호출을 하게 되면 응답을 받아서 이 응답된 데이터를 가지고 데이터를 화면에 이렇게 보여주게 됩니다.
이러한 것들은 우리가 어떤 앱을 딱 들어갔을 때 서버에 있는 데이터를 가져와서 보여주는 그런 상황이고
이때 응답하는 형태가 json이나 xml이라고 보시면 됩니다.
데이터 포맷을 나타냅니다.
이렇게 클라이언트 쪽은 웹과 앱이 각각 https를 통해서 웹서버로 또는 앱에서 api를 통해서 was서버로 요청을 하고 응답을 받는 과정이 있다는 부분이고요.
백앤드 쪽으로 가게 되면 백앤드는 서버와 데이터베이스가 있다라고 말씀드렸는데
이때 데이터베이스에 데이터가 저장되어 있고요.
우리가 사용하는 대부분의 서비스는 데이터를 사용하고 있고 데이터를 저장하고 데이터를 보여주는 그런 것들이 하고 보셔도 무리가 없습니다.
그 데이터가 저장되어 있는 곳이 데이터 베이스이고요.
데이터베이스를 바로 이렇게 프론트앤드 클라이언트가 이렇게 접속을 해서 데이터를 가져와서 보여줄 수도 있지만
그것이 안 되는 또는 그렇게 하지 않는 것은 데이터베이스를 바로 접속하게 되면
이거는 보안의 문제가 있을 수 있고요.
그렇게 데이터가 저장되어 있는 것을 이 백앤드 서버에서 이렇게 중계를 해줍니다.
백앤드 서버, 서버가 하는 대표적인 기능은 API가 있고요.
요청을 응답을 해줍니다.
응답이 정확한 얘기고요.
그리고 데이터베이스와 연동을 하는 부분이 서버의 역할이다.
서버는 기본적으로 리슨이라고 하는데 데이기를 하고 있습니다.
이 모든 통신이 클라이언트가 서버로 요청을 하고 서버는 응답을 해주는 형태라고 보시면 됩니다.
그래서 서버는 이렇게 대기를 하고 있습니다.
리슨을 하고 있는다라고 표현을 하는데요.
서버가 대기를 하고 있다가 클라이언트 요청이 오면 해당하는 요청을 응답해주는 그러한 기능이 서버의 기능이고
웹서버가 그런 역할을 해주게 됩니다.
웹서버는 아파치나 엔진엑스 같은 종류의 서버가 있는데요.
공통적으로 하는 일은 이렇게 HTML, CSS, JavaScript, 이미지 같은 파일들을 가지고 있다가 요청이 오면 해당하는 파일을 응답으로 주게 됩니다.
그래서 이러한 HTML, CSS, JavaScript, 이미지들이 저장되어 있는 그래서 이것을 스테틱 데이터라고도 표현을 합니다.
정적이다라고도 합니다.
이 정적이다라는 표현은 파일들이 고정되어 있고 파일들이 고정된 것을 응답해주는 것이 대부분의 역할이기 때문이고요.
와스는 동적이다라고 표현을 할 수 있는데요.
와스가 동적인 이유는 이 데이터들을 가지고 다시 조합해 가지고 응답을 줄 수도 있기 때문입니다.
그래서 와스가 웹 어플리케이션 서버예요.
웹어플리케이션 서버는 웹서버에 어플리케이션이 들어간 거고요.
이 어플리케이션은 어떤 로직도 담고 있고 대표적인 것은 이렇게 데이터베이스를 조회하고 또는 데이터베이스에 저장하고 삭제하고 수정하는 역할, 그 역할을 하게 된다라는 건데요.
그것이 CRUD라고요.
데이터베이스에 create, read, update, delete를 하는 역할을 합니다.
create는 생성, read는 읽기, update는 수정, delete는 delete.
그래서 현장에서는 CRUD 처리라고도 하는데요.
이것이 sql 문장에 의해서 수행이 됩니다.
sql 문장이라는 것은 데이터베이스를 조작하기 위한, 방금 말씀드린 생성이나 읽기나 수정이나 삭제를 하기 위한 그런 언어이고요.
structured query language라고 해서 데이터베이스를 조작할 수 있는 언어다.
이 언어를 데이터베이스 전달하면 그 요구에 맞는 응답을 해주게 됩니다.
데이터베이스에서 데이터를 가져오는 역할 또는 저장하는 역할, 이것이 sql이다.
이 sql을 어디에 저장하고 데이터베이스에 전달을 하느냐, 그것은 WAS의 어플리케이션이 그것을 가지고 있습니다.
WAS 자체가 가지고 있다기 보다는 WAS 위에는 어플리케이션이 올라가는데요.
이 어플리케이션이 우리가 만드는 back-end 어플리케이션이 되는 겁니다.
이 어플리케이션 안에 이렇게 sql들을 포함하고 있습니다.
그러면 이 특정 요청이 왔을 때 그 해당하는 요구를 맞게 데이터를 가져와서 전달해준 역할.
예를 들면 api에서 조회 또는 입력, 수정, 삭제 이런 것들을 요청을 하게 되는데요.
요청이 왔을 때 조회를 하게 되면 리드겠죠.
그리고 포스트를 하게 되면 크리트, 푸슬하게 되면 업데이트, 딜리트를 하게 되면 딜리트 하는 것과
맵핑을 시켜 가지고 데이터베이스까지 조작을 하게 됩니다.
이것이 back-end에 아주 중요한 역할로 보시면 되겠습니다.
그래서 서버는 주로 Java, Spring, Spring Boot, 여기는 Framework, Java, 언어죠.
Python, 언어, 장고, 플라스크, Framework, JavaScript, 언어, Node.js, Framework 이렇게 좀 구분이 될 수 있는데요.
어쨌든 요런 것들을 통해서 서버 프로그램을 만들게 됩니다.
그러면 이 서버 프로그램 안에서 대표적으로 하는 것들이 api를 개발하는 일이고요.
이 api의 많은 부분이 이렇게 SQL로 데이터를 주건이 확건히 하는 부분이다라고 보시면 되겠습니다.
데이터베이스는 이런 데이터를 체계적으로 저장하는 소프트웨어다라고 보시면 되고요.
대표적으로 MySQL, Oracle 이런 것들이 있습니다.
데이터베이스 안에는 테이블들이 있습니다.
테이블들이 여러 개 있을 수가 있고요.
테이블이라는 것은 데이터를 저장하는 형태이고요.
테이블에는 예를 들면 유저 테이블 또는 프로덕 테이블, 사용자 테이블에는 사용자 이름, 닉네임, 아이디, 이메일 이런 게 있을 수 있죠.
프로덕에는 상품 명, 상품 가격, 상품 설명 이런 것들이 들어있을 수 있죠.
이런 식으로 만들고자 하는 서비스에 저장해야 되는 것들을 테이블이라는 곳에 저장을 하게 됩니다.
테이블은 Excel 표정도를 생각하셔도 됩니다. Excel 표는 가로 세로가 쭉 있죠.
이때 테이블에 이렇게 가로로 한 줄을 레코드라고 합니다.
사용자 테이블에는 예를 들면 하나의 레코드에는 사용자 이름, 아이디, 이메일 이런 식으로 한 사람의 정보가 들어있는
유저 1, 유저 2 이런 식으로 레코드다인으로 쌓여지는 구조.
회원이 하나 추가되면 여기에 하나의 레코드가 추가되는 개념이고요.
Column 이라고 하면 항목 아까 말씀드린 아이디가 Column이고요. 여기에 password가 Column이고 이 사람의 주소가 Column이 됩니다.
그런 식의 형태로 테이블로 저장이 된다고 보시면 되겠습니다.
한번 정리를 해보면 이 앱에서 만약에 어떤 사용자가 어떤 계식을 조회하는 버튼을 클릭했다.
그랬을 때 API가 호출이 되는 것이고 이 Wasp의 어플리케이션에서 데이터베이스에 전달이 되고
데이터베이스는 해당하는 요청의 테이블에 요청한 코드들을 응답을 해줍니다.
그러면 이 응답된 데이터를 이러한 JSON 또는 XML, JSON이 더 많이 쓰여요.
JSON이라는 형태 안에 담아서 답을 해줍니다.
그러면 그 응답된 데이터를 화면에 보여주는 이런 흐름으로 구성되어 있다 라고 보시면 되겠습니다.
여기서 조금씩 다른 부분이 있지만 대부분은 이렇게 구성되어 있다 이렇게 흘러간다 라고 보셔도 좋습니다.
내용이 도움이 되셨다면 좋아요를 눌러주세요.
그러면 제가 관련되어서 계속 영상을 올리도록 하겠습니다.
또 좋은 내용으로 찾아뵙겠습니다.
감사합니다.